and you flip that concept around and we
go to the carolina panthers where
relatively new owner david tepper not
taking any chances not inviting any
acrimony not risking a holdout from
running back christian mccaffrey which i
firmly believe would have happened
without a new deal only the third guy in
league history to have a thousand yards
rushing and a thousand yards receiving
in the same season got his contract this
week four new years on top of the two
that he had left on his rookie deal 16
million per year in new money
one and a half million dollar signing
bonus 30.06 million fully guaranteed at
signing another eight million becomes
guaranteed next year next march into
2022 so this guy is going to be part of
the panthers for a long time and tepper
recognized the talent the work ethic the
leadership the integrity everything
great about christian mccaffrey cam
newton's gone luke keackley's gone greg
olson's gone mccaffrey's the face of the
franchise and tepper made the move now
without playing that year-to-year game
without getting to the franchise tag and
a win-win and this is what the cowboys
could have avoided a year ago with dak
prescott whatever dak wants now it would
have been a hell of a lot less last year
and whatever mccaffrey got now it would
have been a hell of a lot more next year
or the year after that and and this
proves your point peter
strike when you know it's the guy that
you want and if you're paying a little
bit more now than you want to that's
fine because if you wait you're going to
pay a hell of a lot more than you want
to later
you know two things about mccaffrey that
i found very interesting number one
everybody said my god you don't pay
running backs it's a big mistake there's
two things about christian mccaffrey's
case that make him very different
in charlotte and in the carolinas
the billboard player is not the
quarterback and it's not the coach it is
the running back you can only say that
for one team in the nfl that the
billboard person for the franchise is a
running back and that's the case in
carolina so you pay him number two
christian mccaffrey will wake up this
morning at the age of 23.
when le'veon bell signed his four-year
52 million dollar contract with the jets
he was 27 years old christian mccaffrey
at the end of this contract will still
be in his 20s
so the way i look at this is very simply
that you're paying a guy
you almost certainly
you know unless it's an honorarium
will not be paying christian mccaffrey
you know at the end of this contract
this is it this is his big deal so to
keep him off the market to keep him out
of
the time
when the salary cap could be 40 million
more than it is right now to keep them
off the market at that point you pay
them a little bit more now and you build
a series of billboards around the
carolinas and you put his face on it and
that's your guy
yeah he's your guy that sells your team
until you have your next young franchise
quarterback and that gives you a bridge
of three or four years or maybe more
they've got teddy bridgewater under
contract for three seasons and it could
have bridgewater mike you don't know
yeah
and and look here's the easiest argument
for paying christian mccaffrey 16
million a year you're paying bridgewater
21. and and this speaks to the
difference between quarterbacks and
running backs and and and look this
isn't bridgewater's fault because the
market is what it is but my god
christian mccaffrey is worth more to
that team than teddy bridgewater but
because of the position he plays he's
making 5 million less per year on his
new deal
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports